what we're going to talk about in this
video are three theorems that are
sometimes collectively known as
existence theorems
so the first that we're going to talk
about is the intermediate value theorem
and the common thread here all of the
existence theorem say hey we're looking
for something over an interval there
exists an x value between
a and b where something interesting
happens in the intermediate value
theorem we assume
that if we're continuous over the closed
interval from a to b and in fact all of
these existence theorems assume that our
function is continuous over the closed
interval from a to b
then
we take on every value between f a and f
b or another way to think about it is
pick a value from f between f of a and f
of b including f of a or f of b let's
call that value l
the intermediate value theorem tells us
that there if we make the assume the
assumption that f is continuous over
this interval that there must be a value
between a and b that takes on the value
l
and i challenge you try to draw a
continuous function that goes from a
comma f of a to b comma f of b that does
not go through l
if you're continuous you've got to go
through l the only way that you can't go
the other way the only way you could
avoid going through l is if you were
discontinuous if you had a discontinuity
right there then you could avoid going
through l but we're assuming we're
continuous over the interval and so here
it's pretty intuitive that if you're
continuous
there exists a c
between
a and b including it could be a or b
that takes on
any of those values in this case in this
particular value that sits between f a
and f of b so that's the first existence
theorem the second is what's often known
as the extreme value theorem
and this one is similarly intuitive i
think once again it assumes that f is
continuous over a comma over this it
closed interval
but here we say look if it is continuous
over that closed interval then there mu
there exists that's why they're called
existence theorems there exists values
between a and b and it could happen at a
or b
where the function takes on a maximum
and there's a value between a and b
where the function takes on a minimum
value over that interval so once again
try to draw a function that does not
take on a minimum and maximum value over
that interval if i just draw a straight
line here
well then the maximum value happens when
x is b the minimum value happens when x
is a
if i do something
like that
the maximum value occurs once again it
is occurring in this interval it's
occurring right here at c
and then the minimum value is occurring
at a
if i draw something
like let me draw it like this if i draw
something like this
then the minimum value is occurring at
this x value and then the maximum value
is occurring at that value x value this
is just saying that they exist they
exist over that interval and it might
happen at a it might happen at b and
once again the only way i can construct
something where these maximum or minimum
values these extreme values don't exist
is if i make it discontinuous so for
example what if i had a graph that
looked
like
right at where we thought we were going
to have a maximum value we're
discontinuous
well now you don't have a clear maximum
value similarly i could do something
like this
where now we do not have a clear minimum
value and so there does not exist an x
where the function takes on a
a minimum value in that interval but
once again we are assuming that we are
continuous and so we will find these
extreme values and we have other videos
where we go into much more depth on it
last but not least to complete the
trifecta we have the mean value theorem
and this one is also intuitive it starts
going into differentiability in the
derivative and it adds an extra
constraint for us
above and beyond saying that we're
continuous over the closed interval we
also assume that we are differentiable
over the open interval if you're
differentiable over an interval it does
mean that you're continuous but if
you're continuous it does not
necessarily mean that you're
differentiable and all this tells us is
if i have a continuous and
differentiable function over this
interval differentiable over the open
interval continuous over the closed
interval so let me draw that so let me
draw something like this and if i were
to compute the average rate of change
from a comma f of a to b comma f of b
so the average rate of change i will do
in this pink color so that would be the
slope of
this line right over here that would be
the average rate of change the slope of
that line the exit the mean value
theorem tells us that there exists a
point c where the derivative of our
function at that point the slope of the
tangent line at that point is the same
as the average rate of change
and we could eyeball that here it looks
like for this curve there's actually
several points where the derivative
looks the same as the average rate of
change maybe right over here the slope
of the tangent line looks like it has
the exact same slope as the average rate
of change so that could be our c it
exists we feel good it exists well
there's there could be more than one
value right over there it looks like the
slope is the same as the average rate of
change that could also be rc right over
there
so how could we construct something
where this isn't true
well if we don't assume
differentiability over the interval we
can actually find a continuous function
where it isn't true where you can find a
point whose derivative is the same as
the average rate of change so for
example here's my counter case maybe
something like an absolute value
function
where the average rate
where the average rate of change
let me draw a little bit better
so this was an ad some type of an
absolute value function where this is
linear up to this point and then linear
up to this point we're not going to be
differentiable over here so not the
derivative isn't defined at this point
right over here well now you can't at no
point over this interval is the slope of
the tangent line the same as the slope
connect of the or this is the same as
the average rate of change you might try
to make an argument that oh maybe right
over there but we're not differentiable
over there there isn't a well-defined
tangent line or there's a well-defined
tangent line and a well-defined
derivative or slope of a tangent line
so in other videos we'll go into more
depth but it's nice to look at them all
together see what they are all talking
about they're all talking about the
existence of an x value in the interval
where something interesting happens
where we take on a value between f of a
and f b where we take on extreme values
or where the derivative at that point is
the same as the average rate of change
over the interval